hey guys it's Charlie so today we're
gonna be talking about a true life
DC Comics story about Batman and
Superman back during death in the family
recently at New York Comic Con jim
Starlin who's the creator of Thanos muta
mostly known for that but who also wrote
a lot of DC Comics stories revealed that
around the time he was doing the death
in the family storyline there was also
this crazy DC Comics push from editorial
to give a character AIDS so I'm gonna
play this unbelievable story you just
won't believe how nuts it gets you will
be face palming half way through this
and it only gets worse so here we go you
wrote a story for DC where you got to
kill Robin which you know was kind of
shocking at the time but we've the fans
of course voted on this we wanted we
wanted to see this happen so it was did
you get that because you were known as
the death guy no I got that because I
thought going out and fighting crime in
a gray and black outfit while you send
out a kid in primary colors was kind of
like child abuse so when I started
working down Batman I was always leaving
him out Robin out of the stories and
Danny O'Neil who was the editor finally
said you got to put him in and they were
like I'm gonna kill him well it's even
weirder than that it was at the
beginning of the AIDS epidemic and DC
had this great idea they put in a
suggestion box and said which character
should we give age to and we'll do a
special story
this got real dark it's got right dark I
stuffed it with Robins everyday I was
sticking Robins in there
but they recognize my handwriting and
they threw all the Robins out and Jimmy
Olsen one and then they found out the
actor who is playing Jimmy Olsen then
those Superman movies was gay and they
abandoned the whole project no that's
the origin of that particular tale so
the Superman actor the jim Starlin
mentioned in this was mark McClure he's
still alive today like he didn't die of
AIDS or anything like that but you just
you can't believe how not okay something
like that is from editorial so that's
the kind of stuff that would happen back
in the 70s like for PC culture before
things like this were taken a little
more seriously but it is both hilarious
and horrifying at the same time so if
you guys want me to do more videos like
this where I do like you know true
comic-book stories from behind the
scenes that are way more interesting
than a lot of the stuff that they're
doing in the TV shows in the movies
right now then I'll totally do more but
I just saw this story and could not
believe it it was crazy like everybody
knows the story about the one 900 number
of whether or not they should kill Robin
which is a big story in and of itself
but the idea that jim Starlin wanted to
get rid of his Robin get rid of Jason
Todd by giving him aids stuffing the
ballot box is just the craziest thing
ever one because that's just an
absolutely ridiculous way to get rid of
a character to because it's so
completely inappropriate given what was
happening in pop culture at the time
with the AIDS epidemic and as ridiculous
as this all sounds you have to remember
that this is before Geoff Johns Jim Lee
came up in the ranks of DC before a lot
of the big names and comics that you're
reading today even became creators most
of them were little kids reading these
stories when they were happening so let
me know what your favorite comic book
story is from behind the scenes it could
be about the movies or the comics
industry but you typically find more big
crazy stories like this from the days
before social media existed because of
some publisher like Marvel or DC try
some stunt like this everybody would
find out about it instantly and freak
the hell out everybody involved would be
fired and there'd be this huge scandal
so the funny thing about this too is is
that he also talks a lot about the
creation of Thanos and stuff so when we
do more Avengers videos I'll do more jim
Starlin true life stories those old
comic book creators have the best
stories ever stories that would never
make it into the movies or TV shows jim
Starlin said that at various points Stan
Lee hated his guts and would tell the
rest of editorial to ignore all the
stories that he was coming up with so in
slightly happier comic book News Doctor
Strange is coming up I'll be doing a
whole bunch of Doctor Strange videos but
the United States won't be getting the
movie till next week not this week but
next week some of you might be able to
see the movie later this week so please
don't post too many spoilers in the
comments but be sure to subscribe to get
everything
whole bunch of Marvel a whole bunch of
DC coming this week where you guys wait
for my next video you can click up top
for the mirror master flash trailer for
this week's episode and you can click
down here to learn why the Deadpool
movie just completely destroyed everyone
else's marketing campaigns this year
including Captain America and Batman vs
Superman so thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight